yoga helps anxiety after i'm done with
yoga like after yoga i feel good during
yoga that's the most anxiety i've ever
had
in my entire life if you're not familiar
with yoga it's usually me
two gay guys and 25 of the hottest women
i've ever seen in my life
i can't be publicly horny homophobic and
relaxed all at the same time
it's a lot of work it's too sexual to be
relaxing she's like everyone put your
legs over your heads i'm like i was just
going to say that
that's a great idea let's go girls oh me
too oh [ __ ] sorry
i'm trying to check out girls i can't
wear my glasses because it's like too
hot and sweaty then i just can't see
anything so i'm just like squinting
staring at girls
which is a dead giveaway that you're not
focused on your breathing when you're
just standing everyone else is laying
down by the way i'm like oh [ __ ] sorry
and she's like everyone lay down in your
tummies i'm like i can't i have the
largest direction of my entire life
i'm going to teeter-totter from shoulder
to shoulder if i'm laying on my stomach
so i also have a small numba stain in my
shorts
namaste everybody put an end on the end
of it it's a punch line
bang yeah i was uh walking past a uh uh
uh a like a yoga spinning
[ __ ] people's place and the door was
open and i look inside and this teacher
this guy's standing in front of a class
and he's just going like this
and he's going come on come on come on
do it come on
and everybody all strangers that don't
know each other are going like this
and he's going come on come on come on
all right come on
and i thought what [ __ ] power this
guy has
i wish i had that power over people even
without the conceit of a class wouldn't
it be great to be able to do that like
in an airport
a bunch of people waiting at a gate for
a plane it's like come on come on
come on everybody do this oh my god oh
[ __ ] all right jesus why don't we have
to do this
it's [ __ ] i'm late and i gotta
[ __ ] do this
come on youtube come on
i actually took a yoga class it was
great it's amazing the [ __ ] they
they get you to do that you didn't know
what you could do i was doing stuff i
had no idea i was capable of like
sucking two penises at the same time i
didn't think i could do that
mine and his how did i i would it's
actually that flexible
i could sword fight in my own mouth all
right good night thank you everybody
enjoy the show
this may be the dumbest song i've ever
written it's pretty new and uh it's just
about real life so let's do it
my wife was out for three days to visit
her mom
i was supposed to cook and clean while
she was gone
somehow she never buckles under all the
demands
i had to know her secret i had to
understand well i thought it might be
coffee but that gives her the shakes
it might be soap operas but she says
they're too fake
it's not the car she drives or what she
puts in her hair
i realized it's got to be something that
she wears
yoga pants she wears them all day
yoga pants pet working at play
yoga pants what's all the fuss
what makes them so special that they
keep them from us
yoga pants
well any normal person would leave it
alone but i'm not a normal person and
nobody was home
my wife was out of town and the kids
were outside
i went into the bedroom and decided i
would try
yoga pants so stretchy and thin
yoga pants feels like my own skin
yoga pants where you've been all my life
i've never done yoga but these make me
want to try
yoga so soft and so sleek
yoga pants feels good on my cheeks
yoga pants these are the best
if you're waiting for a video don't hold
your breath
[Music]
namaste
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
yoga lunatic maniac dear old billy
redtits uh did you happen to catch the
latest episodes of hbo's real sports
with brian
gumbel uh no i didn't i normally don't
watch on a regular basis but felt
compelled
to check it out after hearing about this
yoga guy on the howard stern show
apparently this nut job is the founder
sledge creator of bikram yoga
named after himself which is done all
over the world and seems like it's
got a crazy cult following basically
people travel all over the world and
spend over ten thousand dollars to take
his classes
because they believe he is some sort of
spiritual leader
now allegations are coming out against
him that he's sexually abused a bunch of
his students
and made all sorts of derogatory remarks
people cannot
handle positions of power you know
you can't have this guy everybody
listening to what he's saying and a
bunch of people bending over in front of
him
he's gonna take his dick out i mean how
did you not see that coming
anyways he told andrea cramer who
conducted the interview
uh why would i have to harass women
uh people spend one million dollars for
a drop of my sperm
he said that
holy [ __ ] that's some of the greatest
[ __ ] talk ever
if that's [ __ ] true
what did she say he said why would i
have to harass
women people spend one million dollars
for a drop of my sperm
oh my god did he [ __ ] drop his lapel
mic and walk off the set
and when asked about whether he harassed
a particular woman he said of course not
i would never even piss on her face
she's a psychopath
this is a yoga instructor this guy
sounds like an assistant coach
he also said it sounds like a gym
teacher he also said he's a million
times smarter than any doctor and that
every doctor in the world comes to him
yeah this guy sounds like donald trump
if he [ __ ] ran a yoga class
donald trump's got to put this guy in
his ticket i
i grabbed the [ __ ] he pisses in their
face trump
bikram 2017. uh this guy seems like he's
a little out of his tree
uh just wanted to hear what old freckles
has to say about this i posted some
links to the story slash video below
um oh it's on the huffington post i i
don't go to that website those guys are
they're [ __ ] weird man they always
act like they're this really like big
like like credible news source and then
if you just look at the [ __ ] they have
you know top 10
[ __ ] celebrity nose jobs in the
corner um
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself i'll look
for those links i'm not going to that
website though
um jesus christ what a [ __ ]
lunatic i gotta see that man
[Music]
great interview huh as far as like you
know he's gonna give you the quotes
and as much as people at bryant gumbel's
real sports were appalled
they were they were secretly high-fiving
each other for the [ __ ] ratings that
that was going to get
he said i gotta read go back what the
[ __ ] these
why do i have to harass women people
spend one million dollars for a drop of
my sperm
yeah that's what happens when people fly
around the [ __ ] world to come to your
yoga class
you people people go crazy they can't
[ __ ] handle it